[Music]  what's up bleacher report i'm michael  carter williams and i'm taking on  soon to be rookie michael smith and  mike's hard lemonade seltzer's  battle of the mics nobody makes lemonade  like mike's they are the experts so  we're going against each other to see  who's the expert on the court for  today's episode  a skills challenge yes sir oh mike  you're missing over there watch me take  this win  easy there's only one mic here that's me  me smith  good luck mike  [Music]  yes sir  oh my god  there it is  that's game man he got lucky  the best mike listen hey good game bro  you know i gave him my all went through  the cones with speed  pass was picture perfect and all i hear  is just this  man you know what i mean it's one mic  and the one mike is in miami right now  and he just won i'll see you in the next  episode mike i'll see you in the next  episode